hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 36 hört zu und spricht nach
ich wohne in einem haus ich wohne in
einem haus ich wohne in einem reihenhaus
ich wohne in einem reihenhaus ich wo
in einem mehrfamilienhaus ich wohne in
einem mehrfamilienhaus
[Musik]
in einem hochhaus ich wohne
einem hochhaus ich wohl
im erdgeschoss ich wohne im erdgeschoss
ich wohne im ersten stock
im ersten stock ein
ist im zweiten stock meine
ist im zweiten stock die arztpraxis ist
im dritten stock die arztpraxis ist im
dritten stock mein büro ist im vierten
stock
[Musik]
eur ist im vierten stock wo
im fünften stock wohnst du im fünften
stock mein haus hat drei stockwerke mein
haus hat drei stockwerke meine wohnung
hat einen balkon
[Musik]
meine wohnung hat einen balkon
meine wohnung hat zwei badezimmer meine
wohnung hat zwei badezimmer zu meiner
wohnung gehört ein garagenplatz zu
meiner
wohnung gehört einen garagenplatz ich
wohne an
ich wohne alleine
ich wohne mit meinem freund zusammen
mit meiner freundin zusammen ich wohne
mit meiner freundin zusammen
ich wohne mit meiner familie zusammen
mit meiner familie zusammen ich wohne in
einer wohngemeinschaft ich
einer wohngemeinschaft meine nachbarn
sind laut meine nachbarn sind laut meine
nachbarn sind nett meine nachbarn sind
nett meine nachbarn sind hilfsbereit
meine nachbarn sind hilfsbereit
meine nachbarn machen oft um meine
nachbarn machen oft lernen im glück
hier gibt es eine waschmaschine in der
küche gibt es eine waschmaschine in der
kür
gibt es einen kühlschrank in der küche
gibt
einen kühlschrank in der
das einen herd in der küche
gibt es einen herd mein auto steht in
der garage man auf
steht in der garage mainau
steht auf dem parkplatz ein auto
dem parkplatz main
vor dem haus mein auto
dem haus im
immer hängt ein fernseher an der wand im
wohnzimmer
fernseher an der wand
steht ein esstisch im wohnzimmer steht
ein esstisch im wohnzimmer gibt es ein
sofa im wohnzimmer gibt es ein sofa im
badezimmer
eine dusche im badezimmer
das eine dusche im badezimmer gibt es
eine badewanne im badezimmer
das eine badewanne im badezimmer hängt
ein spiegel im bad
immer hängt ein spiegel der haus habe
wechselt die lampen aus der haut
wat wechselt die lampen aus der haut
kunst das treppenhaus der haut
das treppenhaus der haus
abwischt vor dem eingang der haut
erwischt vor dem eingang